explain to me um how meditation has been
for you and just like what what is i
don't think people understand like
exactly how to do that
like it's it's you know what i mean like
give us that breakdown and like when you
say you reach the peak of your
meditation what do you you know what are
you alluding to so pretty much like as i
mean okay so when i first started
meditating i was receiving
visions same day i like i like
meditating my eyes would like take like
lights like i could meditate with a
certain type of squint
in my eyes it was crazy i used to be
able to take like certain pictures or
whatever that was in my
eyesight and bring them together and
make visions out of them it was crazy it
was like some [ __ ] i never seen before
like one thing
one thing i cannot remember it was some
delivery company i think it was fedex or
something
some damn ups or something i was looking
at it while i was meditating and i think
i broke down the whole letter and it
made like a symbol it was like an eye
and some it was like weird i was
breaking down everything like my third
eye was really moving i would have
dreams i have like strong ass dreams
where i'd be able to feel like i was
really there i still had those dreams
but it was more stronger because it was
something i wasn't accustomed to it
wasn't a lifestyle it was like getting
introduced to it but now it's like i
still have those dreams but i almost
don't have like divisions or certain
things like that but um i feel like i
just reached the peak of
my independence of meditation now i want
to implement certain things like
like tribal and meditations or like
meditating with like a group of people
like certain stuff that can strengthen
what i got going on like mushrooms yo
shrooms too or have you ever heard of
ayahuasca ayahuasca i have heard of that
i have already gotta go to come up with
a plan huh yeah you gotta go to costa
rica get a shaman
prepare drink that [ __ ] and then you
know
when i heard ayo oscar
i heard a some tool reset is is that not
where it resets your whole mind yeah
that's what they say ayahuasca yup they
say it's like they're like
i had a friend do do it and he said it
was like 30 years of therapy in like one
day yeah so yeah i'm like [ __ ]
that's pretty that's pretty deep